[Music]
you're listening
to inside of you with michael rosenbaum
or
watching on youtube where you can also
subscribe
ryan good afternoon good afternoon it's
a special day we have a special surprise
for you at the end of the show
in the outro and uh i think you'll think
of a
as a nice surprise it will be a nice
surprise i think yeah yeah
it's uh something that hasn't happened
in over a year oh
niapan yeah a year yeah we've got a
great guest today
talking about talk about mental health
talk about a guy who lets
it all out puts it all out there on the
table and says this is me
this is what happened this is who i am
this is what i think of everything
and man it blew me away and i just
david hare would just uh knock me off my
socks with some of his stories and his
honesty and
i really really appreciated him to come
on and
be uh divulge so much um before we get
into that
uh letting you know that my band sunspin
has a concert
and it's coming up very soon it is this
coming saturday
may 29th 2 p.m 6 p.m pacific standard
time
you can get tickets if you just go to
sunspin.com
they could redirect you there you could
also get merch you can get uh you could
book me for a
zoom or you book us for the band for a
zoom and
uh you could book the band if you want
people have done that there we've played
an outdoor place and it's been fun uh
did you just burp
did well thank you
i can't hide the stuff that validates my
band sunspend
you could also follow us at sunspin band
on all social media which would be
really really nice and on spotify follow
us please we're now on spotify and
trying to get those listeners up and i
think you'll enjoy the the the band the
album
sun's been called best days uh inside of
you online store is open
we've got lex luthor stuff small the
lunchboxes left we've got
hats and shirts and mugs and tumblers
and just all sorts of fun stuff
so you might want to go there and if you
want to follow the podcast you could do
that ryan
at inside of you pod on twitter inside
of your podcast
on instagram and facebook there's a dog
just walked in out
please get the hell out i love you get
the hell out thank you
you already had your walk she just comes
in here like what's going on
um and it please subscribe i always say
this but it really helps the show when
you subscribe you tell others and if
you're enjoying yourself and you you
like the podcast you wanted to continue
i would ask you to just uh get other
people to listen
and subscribe guys i love you thank you
to all my patrons
uh i'd love you to join patreon.com
inside of you join the family
i will send you a message right after
you join uh it helps the podcast on the
side you get the little perks there's
tiers
check it out patreon.com inside of you
and um patreon's a good time so i hope
you uh
you join the family and um i'm still
trying to have camp rosie
and that's gonna probably happen next
year and uh if you're a patron
you'll be invited first there are
guidelines you know
um and things like that you know but
it'll be a lot of fun
trying to have as much fun in my life as
i can trying to enjoy things more trying
to enjoy
you know what hey i'm really today i
feel positive i feel i'm
just i'm happy i'm proud of myself for
sticking with this
podcast i'm proud of uh you guys are
thankful more
more for being grateful for you guys for
sticking with me
i'm always talking about how i want to
grow the audience and all that but at
the end of the day it's
i still love doing it i still love
everyone uh
big shout out to cumulus and uh
to ryan my editor engineer and to bryce
who
tries to make these or does make these
shows even better by
tightening them up and giving you a
little giving you a
something pleasant to listen to i hope a
great podcast with kiefer sutherland
and jason patrick people are talking
about that charisma carpenter from last
week people are loving that
a lot of stuff went viral if you haven't
listened to it erica christensen from
parenthood and traffic
we try to get into it and uh today we're
gonna get into it so
without further ado from the show
supergirl he's been in tons of stuff
he has a fascinating fascinating story
so brace yourself let's get inside of
david harewood
it's my point of view you're
listening to inside of you with michael
rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
since you're filming do you have to get
coveted test constantly three times a
week dude
and how much do you hate it on a scale
from one to eight
it's necessary and actually we feel to
be honest with you
i feel safer on set than i do um
offset because at least i know on set
everyone's tested and
um you know everyone's playing by the
rules whereas
you know in real life you know you don't
know you don't know who's doing what so
so um uh i feel quite safe i feel quite
safe on set and
they've they've gone some way to to
making us feel
very safe with each other well you know
i've talked to a lot of actors and
i hear all the stuff because i i've
chosen not to act during this time and
you know i hear on set it's you know
you're you're wearing masks
sometimes they have these little devices
you have to put on to rehearse these
certain masks these like plexiglas
things it just it just feels like it's
uh you know it's
when you're on set you want to be
comfortable you're already in your head
you want to be great you want to do your
job
and now you got all this other [ __ ]
around you it feels like it's a pain in
the ass and it takes time to at least
get used to how many i mean how long
have you been doing it like this
well since the beginning um and it's
it's um it's uh
it's tough man it's tough you know as i
say
it's a it's it's not a great way to go
out this is our last season
um so you know i mean i still don't know
what after makeup girls look like
you know it's like everyone's got this
mask so
we're all sort of shrouded in [ __ ]
gel and
um and masking and ppe and
it it does occasionally get um
annoying and grating but it's it's
listen if
if it's keeping everybody safe let's
just just let's do it
are there some actors that you're uh
working with you don't give me names but
just like while you're doing it they're
just they they can't deal some deal with
it better than others but someone like
[ __ ] come on
i [ __ ] got this [ __ ] mask on and
they just
everyone's really getting into it
everyone's you know everyone's really
uh everyone's really really um
the pitching in because you know i mean
you know i mean
you know that the very first lockdown
you know that was the first time in nine
years that i've
stopped working um wow and it was it was
great
it was great and it was it was it was
nice to be um
suddenly you find that you could
you know you would you would had been
told to stop and
it was very refreshing i had to say very
refreshing but towards the end of it you
know i started to realize i think
um i feel very lucky that some of my
friends haven't worked
a day since the whole thing started so
um i feel very lucky that i'm working
uh and very fortunate that i'm working
and this it's a
[ __ ] pandemic i mean so many people
have lost their jobs yeah
i've gotten money and and are really
struggling so so i guess i i feel very
grateful
um that that i've i've had the
opportunity to work
and even more grateful that everybody on
set is pitching in
and um getting on with it yeah do you do
you feel like you're someone who has to
work like i know a lot of my friends who
if they're not working they go insane i
think i go a little insane do you feel
like
uh the anxiety creeps in all these other
start these outside factors you get you
get inside your head if you're not
working
um maybe back in the day um but you know
that but
but um that was to do
with um just trying to keep a roof over
their head you know i mean you know when
you're when you're skinned and you you
know you
and you and you know you're just jobbing
going from job to job and the
opportunities of opportunities are um
are rare and um
you know it can get very frustrating and
you know you you just you just want to
be
not just want to be working you want to
be i can remember
a week two a couple of weeks before stay
you know i got homeland
staring up in the [ __ ] city you know
two kids in the in the other bedroom
i couldn't pay the rent i couldn't pay
the mortgage i didn't i broke
and i so so it was it was it was a case
of
you know i've got to work you know i've
got to get out there
and and and find a gig you know maybe i
need to
you know go drive a bus or something you
know because because you've got to make
some money unfortunately
those days seem to be behind me um
but i'm not i'm not like i don't know i
don't always have a jones for work i
mean i
i'm really looking forward to getting to
the end of this current gig
and kind of reassessing and spent
and saying no i haven't been in a
position to say no to
work for um years uh
or ever so it's going to be nice to
sit back and and choose the direction i
want to go next as opposed to
having to jump on something just because
i need to pay the mortgage yeah it seems
like there'd be a lot more stress too
not only when you're trying to support
two kids
and put a roof over your head but at the
same time you're on set
and you just have a new job and this is
it you're like oh my god this means so
much so much more
than a lot of people when they're
working and they take it for granted
people take it for granted but
it just seems like the pressure to be
great to be good to keep your job would
be
more intense did you feel like that in
the first uh
first go at it yeah i mean i've never
done an american accent before so
so it was you know huge pressure on me
to to
i had 16 days from getting the getting
the gig to starting the gig
so there was pressure on me to to you
know learn the accent
um uh and you know you're working
opposite you know
great actors mandy patinkin claire danes
you know and i i've been out of work for
nine months
and so so it it took some sort of mental
it took a leap of sort of mental faith
and
and sort of belief in yourself to to get
there and go you know what i'm going to
put all that [ __ ] out
out of my head i'm just going to turn up
on the day and try and be the best that
i can be
but you know it's it's it was
nerve-racking yeah
you're trying to put all that stuff out
well it just seems like fear
is something that i know as an actor you
get right away when you get the job and
someone's like you're hired
and then all of a sudden can i do it can
i you know all these and you're like
what are you talking about you've been
doing this you've done this your whole
life how do you
and then that fear it's overwhelming and
then the more you work on it the more
you start to do things that starts to
dissipate or whatever absolutely and you
you know it's you're never gonna
not have that fear you know you know you
always i think most actors
the first day for most actors is always
a little bit nerve-wracking oh yeah
because you know you're in a new company
um
dealing with expectations uh you know
i've known actors
be fired after the read through
you know to get the job and then be
fired after the retreat or get the job
and be fired after a couple of days you
know it's it's so
you never feel 100 um
you can't feel 100 safe right you know
so
so i think you know going in just do it
giving your best
if you give it your best because you
know and it doesn't work out
you know you've got to just take your
hats off to that and uh you know i've
been close to that in a couple of a
couple of once or twice
um but you know you can only do your
best now um
you know if i turn up my best my best
isn't good enough
it's not good enough i know i say that
see i i say that david i say
you know what [ __ ] him do your [ __ ] do
what you do
and if it all falls apart and then it
falls apart and you're like where's
tough guy now
huh where's the tough guy and i i
haven't been fired a lot but i've been
fired before where
i sat there and i hung up the phone i
you know the producer calls me and he
was in tears because he was like this is
a shock
i you know we already shot the thing and
i remember he says
like i just want to get to it but you
know this is the way it is and
and i said hey listen let's not make
this weird i love you i love working
with you let's just you know hey we'll
keep in touch man i appreciate the job
and i hung up and i i it was one of
those moments where i'm numb
you're numb and you look at the ceiling
and you see the one
spot of black or whatever it is on the
ceiling and you just stare at it
and then i took a deep breath and i go
my dog came up to me and i go oh but
look i have this dog
and i have a roof over my head and i'm
not dead
and i started to say these gratitudes
which kind of helped even though i half
believed them half didn't but
i've been in that position where you're
like okay
and you're almost embarrassed i think
you are i think part of it's
embarrassment like everybody's going to
know i got
fired no one's going to hire me i i'm
you know
it's it's a very difficult kind of thing
you could easily spiral downward
but i did without a doubt that's why
it's important to
i'm sure your dog pulled you out of it
you know but it's important to
to have uh you know
you know to to have that strength of
mind i think you know i i you know
i say i did a documentary a couple years
ago one failure
in the acting industry and it's really
interesting how
at first nobody wanted to talk to me
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] i i'm not touching that you know
i don't know
but you know once i started kind of
opening up the subjects and
talking about difficult times they've
had in their careers or
a bad review series or bad reviews a bad
word
you know you start to understand it's
just another part of the business
that you have to navigate you know yeah
you can be on the highs the highs are
great
[ __ ] eyes are great getting work
money all that's great but the lows are
loads are hard and sometimes the lows i
think
you learn more in the lows than you do
in the highs
it's in the lows when you sit there and
go let me [ __ ] figure let me think
about this
think about this i mean how am i doing
today you know you really have to
work on yourself and really kind of get
in touch with with with
you know with something that i i you
know i think
will teach you resilience you'll learn
resilience you know you
you don't learn anything from success
you know you just bob along when
everything's going well yeah it's
great it's only when you hit a hard time
that you go
let me ask you you start asking yourself
questions start thinking
am i tough enough to get through this
i'm like am i resilient enough to get
through this
can i you know can i push through this
difficult time and
i've had difficult times you know right
now things are
great but um if i hadn't had those tough
times i don't think i'd appreciate
the times i where where i am now
so i you know i i see i see i see those
dark days
as as a part of the business and um
uh to be to be embraced
just as much as as the uh never
successful
yeah and when you when you think about
it especially nowaday
with twitter and everybody's just
on to the next thing that failure what
is it really
you know you do something you're on
twitter for maybe a minute
and then you're gone and i start to say
to myself michael
no one gives a [ __ ] about you really no
one gives a [ __ ]
just [ __ ] do it and if you fail
somebody's gonna go oh my god he fell oh
next thing oh look at this this guy fell
on his head
you know what i mean it's one of those
things where it's just what's the word
it just it's ephemeral it's
short-lived it's it's and that that
gives me comfort
in a way knowing that i'm not that
[ __ ] important
that's that's it's not that important
you know it really isn't you know it's
you know
keep people dying of cancer incognito
you know i mean there's real stuff going
on
in the world and you know i i i you know
i think
you've got to keep keep it keep a handle
on them
you know allowing things to spiral out
of control did you always want to be an
actor
no i mean i i i don't know you know i
i was i was a bit of a clown at school
you know i've been a [ __ ] idiot
um just i i wasn't very academic i just
didn't find it interesting
and um i do now which is weird
you know but you know i i don't think
then i was developed enough to
really understand the the uh
finer points of geography and sociology
i was like
how am i gonna apply i was i'm gonna
apply any of this to my life because
it all seems like nonsense so i couldn't
really ever tune into it so i was
messing around and back of class and
and um i was always up for a school play
always up for a message
you know always up for jumping into
school plays and stuff and at the end of
my school i was about five weeks away
from leaving school and a teacher
called me called me uh called me at home
and said you know come into the school
he'd like to talk to you so
i went in and um didn't know what he was
gonna say and he you know he said you
said
what are you gonna do when you leave
school here wouldn't it i don't know
you know trump on my shoulders and he
just said well we've been talking in the
staff room and
we all think you should be an actor
[ __ ] light bulb went on in my head
i just went [ __ ] course
that sounds like a great idea not not
knowing how you did it
how you became one it just it just
seemed to fit my sort of
uh world view um
and i sort of um spend the next
uh you know two three years
auditioning going to dr going to went to
the national youth theater
i was told that at the national
europeans i was invited back to the
national youth in the following year and
they said i should go to drama school
so auditioned for a load of drama
schools and got into radha which is one
of the best drama schools in the [ __ ]
world
and i had no idea that that was gonna
you know it was all cause it was all a
flu because i
i actually cancelled my radar audition
because i got in somewhere out not
knowing anything about drama schools i
wrote off to a whole load of drama
schools
uh rejected from the first three
and uh went to the next one and was
accepted
and just cancelled all the remaining
auditions
which happen to be the remaining ones
with the top five drama schools in the
country
and for some bizarre reason
the rada letter never arrived the my
cancellation letter
never arrived so they phoned me the day
after i was supposedly supposed to be
there
and asked me why i didn't turn up and i
just old face lied i said when
probably my mother was ill and they said
well it's your lucky day because
somebody's dropped out
on friday you know which was the next
following day said would you like
another shot i went yeah sure
i just went down without care in the
world didn't give a [ __ ]
yeah you know and i got in and um i
cancelled the
crack place which ended up going to
rather
royal academy of dramatic arts you got
into
almost as an accident now yeah i mean
do you think if those people didn't call
you in high school
and say look david we think you
you never would have done it i could i
get it
and this is a this is a this is a um
you know i i touch upon this and i'm
writing my i'm just writing my first
book
and i touch upon this in that this sense
of value
that that that i i've struggled with i
have a
you know in britain as a young black kid
weren't any black people on television
there was very
few depictions of black success
uh you know in in in on british
television
so my as a working class first
generation immigrant
child i was very my expectations of
what i could do were really quite basic
you know i thought it was probably a
factory or a assembly line or you know
i didn't i didn't i didn't i didn't even
i didn't think it was possible for me to
be an actor
you know i just had no you know so if
they hadn't suggested it
i certainly wouldn't have tried tried to
do it i just would have thought that
stuff was
off limits to me um and it took me a
while to
settle into that into the profession
into the into the kind of mold
um but but that sense of value it's i've
been battling with it for years
years because you know i
i've had a america's given america has
given me
a load of it it's given me a load of
that
at that of that acknowledgement you know
homeland come on in
you know supergirl come on in try to
direct the show let's
direct the show it's even a movie here's
a movie
you know and i've never had any of that
in england
never had any of it so it was sort of
it's my sense of value i think i found
my sense of value
uh in america so it's gonna be
interesting to go back to england
which is really not given me very much
um to to see if i can maintain this
sense of self-worth because uh it's a
it's it's a battle in england it's about
do you feel like there's more
racism there did you feel like growing
up that it was just like you could just
feel it you felt like
you know they're looking at me
differently there did you feel it there
well i mean you know this is an
interesting conversation to be having
with an american because you know i mean
american
it's it's an it's an admitted fact in
america racism isn't the biggest fact in
america
yeah you talk about openly talked about
it's a fact of life you deal with it
whereas in england
baptism there was a report literally
just released this morning
which apparently says institutional
racism doesn't exist
racism it doesn't exist uh uh
britain is a beacon of diversity around
the world
and we should look for other reasons as
to why
a disproportionate number of people of
color are still at the bottom end of the
socio-economic ladder
i mean it's the ultimate gaslighting
that britain
is is is involved with right now to say
that
you know besides this whole thing with
not that i'm a royalist
at all that's something with megan and
harry and all this stuff you know
the the following day after that
interview when oprah's interview went
out
[ __ ] britain was shaking us racist
we're not racist it's your fault how
dare you say we're racist
in england to accuse somebody of racism
to to point out racism in england is to
accuse somebody of being
is to leave yourself open to accusation
accusations of being called the racist
so you can't even have the discussion in
britain because it's denied
it's ignored it's it's disparaged
uh so i can't even have that
conversation so all this
you know it it's it's a it's a very
peculiar
mindset that that that
we find ourselves in in britain and it's
so
so it's it's that that ties into my
and i'm not surprised as to why so many
you know did a documentary a couple
years ago about mental health and
you know black britons are 10 times more
likely to suffer from
mental health conditions four times more
likely to be sectioned
under the mental health act and it's no
surprise because
you're look you've been gasoline the
whole the whole time
by people who tell you that your life
experience your limited experience
actually doesn't matter or is a figment
of your imagination
so um it's a tough one
in england it's a really
really tough one there
inside of you is brought to you by
geico geico you know
ryan you rent your home yeah you do it
it's probably the most difficult thing
for people to do
is rent their home mortgage pay their
mortgage and they got this auto policy
they got these things it's difficult
it's difficult to pay you got to pay one
person over here
you got to do another person over here
so
the thing to do is geico has a bundling
policy
you just pay for all of it it's easy you
know what i mean
echo makes it easy to bundle your
homeowners and renters insurance along
with your auto policy
it's a good thing because we've got so
much going on so much to do around the
home
just do me a favor go to geico.com
get a quote see how you could save
how much you could save this guy co-easy
visit geico.com today that's
geico.com even a rose and bomb can do it
inside of you is brought to you by nitsa
in 2019 nearly 10 000 people were
unbuckled when they were killed in
crashes
that's 43 percent of people killed
in motor vehicle crashes that were not
wearing seat belts you know ryan it's
always the same thing
i'm not going very far i'm in a rush
what are you going to rush about this is
your life and it's uncomfortable
sometimes i just forget don't kid
yourself there's no such thing as an
excuse for not buckling up if you used
any of these excuses
or any others you're putting yourself at
risk or injury of injury or death you're
not only putting yourself
i always say to my friends you know
you're putting other people at risk
that's what i'm concerned about no
matter what kind of vehicle you drive
wearing your seatbelt is the best
defense in a crash
even when you sit in the back seat you
still need to buckle up come on
that goes for you when you're riding
taxis you use ride sharing services too
why do people feel
like oh i'm indestructible i'm in the
back of an uber i'm safe
you're not safe wear your seatbelt law
enforcement are on the lookout
writing tickets so why take the risk
seat belt save lives
do the smart thing and buckle up every
trip
day or night please click it
or ticket paid for by nitza inside of
you is brought to you by my good friends
at untuck it i freaking
love this product i am a ambassador
i want to be the ambassador for untuck
it because i love these shirts i'm
wearing one now
you look great right look at that it's
such a good fit and you know the great
thing is untuck it makes shirts designed
to be worn
untucked i don't know how many times
i've worn these shirts and people like
hey rosie nice dress
i'm like oh thank you what your shirt's
really long dude
all these other shirts these dress
shirts or you know these short sleeve
button downs
they're never designed to just feel free
and walk around they're designed to tuck
in
these aren't they have fits for all
shapes and sizes
untuck it offers up to triple xl plus
they have slim relaxed and tall fits
untucked it has 85 stores nationwide
free returns and exchanges
the short sleeve shirt button downs i
just bought four extra ones i didn't
even get the discount for it i just
wanted them and i wanted them now and i
love them so much and i'll be wearing
them throughout this
uh throughout doing these podcasts i
really love these guys
untucked shirts are perfect as we
transition back into the things that
we've been missing like the uh
the dinner with friends the reuniting
with uh family
vacations you put a few untucked shirts
in there and the ladies
or the gents are gonna dig you they're
gonna like you i really like this
it's this easy guys use code
inside for 20 off your first purchase
at untuckit.com just go to untuckit.com
and type in the code inside for 20
off i mean look at this shirt
need i say more do you ever go back
to your old teachers who brought you in
that day i always feel like there's
you know there's a certain amount of
people who believe in you while you're
growing up that help you
in your career whatever it is there's
like i could i could pick there's like a
handful
that said that they believed in me they
kept bringing me back
did you ever go see them oh yeah i mean
i went to see um
i actually did a documentary with the t
the very teacher who
told me to be an actor uh we um
uh looked at a documentary back at my
old school um where wait
where he used to teach me and the uh
producers at one point
um sent him in the room uh as i was
teaching these students about acting
they sent him in the room to sort of
surprise me and it was a real it was
quite emotional
because literally everything that i
all the clothes the roof over my head
has all come from acting
and uh i i wouldn't have done that if it
wasn't it wasn't for that one man what
was his name uh
mr reader eric reader um and i
thanked him a million times uh quoted
him a million times
and um you know he literally
redirected my entire life so did you cry
did you cry when you saw him i did i
choked up a little bit i've got to be
honest with you yeah it's it's i kind of
always do because i
i kind of think if it wasn't for him i
don't know what i'd be doing now
i'd probably be i don't know what i
don't know i don't know what i'd be
doing i'd probably be um
it's it's it's it's it's something
thinking about
because because uh there really aren't
that many opportunities
to get out acting is a great way of
getting out
and i've been successful at it um i've
been very lucky
lucky and lucky you know with with what
it's given me
but uh short of that
i don't know what i don't know where
where would i have succeeded how would i
have
how would i have traveled how would i
have seen the world how would i
experience life um it's it's kind of
frightening to think about it
do you think were you ever like i was
one of those guys who was just
uncomfortable with who i was i didn't
know who i was i didn't have a lot of
confidence
you know yeah i didn't hear i love you
from my dad i didn't hear you're good i
didn't hear any of that [ __ ] so when i
started acting
it was the first time people noticed me
so i felt like oh
as long as i don't have to be me i'm
good
so being these characters being in shows
being getting this acknowledgement
that's what saved me ultimately and also
has
slowly destroyed me in a lot of ways
because that's the only way i know what
success is i'm like
oh happiness is having someone tell you
you're great
oh that feels good but then it goes away
right it goes away so it's not sustained
i um i didn't remember you know
you know doing good theater for a while
and
you know having some some success in
theater and then you know you know
getting on the television and
you know you know making money and being
on the tv every couple of nights and
you know the girls are looking at you
and all this and you can get into the
clubs and suddenly and people are
finally drinking it's great
for a while get laid a couple of times
oh yeah
you know but then it very quickly lost
its luster to me i
very quickly got dull and boring
and um i'm glad i went through it as as
as a uh as an experience but
there's there's uh you know all that
recognition stuff and this
desire for um for uh some kind of
acceptance or acknowledgement
i i i it wasn't about that for me it
very quickly wasn't about that for me
because
it was um you know i love doing what i
do uh
uh i love telling stories uh and i love
acting and
uh but it's not it's not something i do
for
acknowledgement anymore i think i used
to but but i
i do it and then you know there's this
there's been times when i've just don't
got the money
uh but but now i'm really trying to do
it because i want now i want to do it
because i
really enjoy the art form and i really
enjoy
you know working with specific people
and um
uh you know i want to get a specific
thing out of a specific role so
so it's not it's no longer about the
acknowledgement from the outsider
for me that's a healthy attitude and
that takes that takes some time
it's taken me 30 years you know it's
taken me 30 years
you know i'm i'm you know and i've just
written this book as i said
where i've sort of because i had a
nervous i had a breakdown such a
psychotic breakdown when i came out of
drama school
two years out of drama school spent two
weeks in the mental institution
and um it was tough you know i
lost my mind um and
i kind of recovered from that
sort of got better put in a box
buried it for 30 years and
a couple years ago did a documentary
where i retraced my steps to find out
what the [ __ ] that was all about
um which was really scary and very
uh it was very scary time because i
as i said i i buried it so deep i i
didn't think i'd
ever find it but throughout doing this
documentary
it was suddenly right there you know the
pain of what
why i'd gone crazy and and
it's just the reality of of having a
breakdown
you know really came home and that was
that was the uh my psychosis in me on
the bbc was that
me uh uh it was really tough the
toughest thing i've ever done
but i was given i was given my medical
records
uh during a sequence of filming
and um i couldn't look at it i i looked
at it once and it
terrified me it's a it's a record of all
the things i said as i was crazy
and it's really tough to read and uh
i put it in an envelope and i put it on
the shelf at the back there
and i didn't look at it for two years
and um
when i started to write this book i knew
i had to look at it
i knew i had to look at it so i spent
six months with it looking at it reading
it
and it was scary but uh now that i've
sat with it
now that i've been with that pain and
been with that been with all that
confusion
all the stuff that sent me crazy it's
actually made me stronger i feel
better i feel like i got in touch with
the things that really made me
vulnerable the things that really made
me
uh that took me over the edge you know
and
you know i've sort of deciphered the
things that i'm saying sort of
almost like almost like how you can
interpret a dream
but i i think i've sort of interpreted
the things i'm saying and
it's been a really interesting journey
to
uncover your deepest darkest secrets
and um and to look at your crazy self
uh and sort of come to terms with it
and kind of and kind of hold it and not
be afraid of it
and and i i feel as though
um i feel as though it's been a really
healing
process for me and now
there's not really that much that um
terrifies me or frightens me or
or um you know i feel i feel very i feel
very
in possession of of myself for the first
time in
in many many many years and i can be
really honest with myself
so i i don't think i could be before
um so i feel pretty good about i've been
pretty good about where i am and
and the work that i've been doing on
myself i still see a therapist
um that you know that sort of
that i speak to every week and that's
been really helpful
really really helpful and remember it
keeps me in touch with
the work on self and you know this could
be very isolating
you know what it's like when you're
working away you're in a hotel room or
you're in an
apartment somewhere and it's even it's
even more
crazy in kobe because you know we're
literally we've kind of subtly been
asked not to go out
or subtly being asked not to go down and
go to a bar or
go to a restaurant because you could
catch coffee right so we're all sort of
going to work
and coming home go to work come home go
to work come on and that's it that's
been it for like
five months and it's been it's been
mind-numbingly
tough yeah but um the book
you know i sat here and i spent my time
writing the book and
and um and uh
i've it's been a really i think this
whole period has been very
has been uh been very helpful for me to
kind of get in touch with something
which is a bit deeper
well you know you're incredibly brave
and i i say that with the utmost respect
because
you know i talk a lot about anxiety
depression therapy and things like that
it's kind of something that just comes
up a lot of times uh
you know i had the guy stephen amell
who's a friend of mine from arrow had an
anxiety attack on the show and he
said record it keep it going air it i
want
this is important and that's brave and
like
you know i look at what you've done and
what you're doing and a lot of people
would say
you know thank god now it's starting to
open up a little where
people are talking about therapy they're
talking about maybe see it used to be
where no one talked about and i came
from a household where my dad wouldn't
even go near it you know he easily could
say the word crazy or this but
you know and he has his own things his
own issues but i look at you as somebody
who opens up and says this is
my life this is this is what happened
this is what i overcame
what i faced and it's just huge i mean
it's
you know and i think about when you said
you had that break and you went to a
mental institution
and the first thing that came to mind
was well what caused that break
like was it is it partly genetic is it
uh
something you were going through it was
you're not yourself you couldn't what
what what happened to get you to that
point
uh mixture of things you know it was
partly partly was genetic
my father had a breakdown so i guess it
should have put me on high alert
um and you know i've learned so much
you know through the investigation of
trying to understand
what what what psychosis is um
uh but yes my father had
about hypertension uh and i have rea and
as i say i have learned that it can
it can be genetic it can pass from um
through the family um but but also you
know
first generation uh you know uh uh
uh um immigrants um being in the city
uh can cause it adolescence can cause it
you know trainings and through this i've
been staggered but i have to say buddy
staggered by the number of
young actors who have had breakdowns
young
um students who've had breakdowns a
number of people once but like when i
did my
when my documentary came out at least
three
teachers principals independently called
me after the documentary came out
and said thank you for doing what you
did amazing documentary
but can you please speak to my student
he's a he's a young black kid
he's had a breakdown as well and you
know you know he's seen what you've done
and
can you speak to him and kind of pull
him out of it and i couldn't do it at
the time because i was just too raw the
whole [ __ ] thing was just it just
left me just
it really left me really raw and exposed
i'm better now but i but when it went
out i
[ __ ] whole world was like knew my
business and
and uh it was tough because i'd walk
down the street next day
and people were and i've always you know
as as actors we have this sort of veneer
of
unapproachability sometimes where people
are a little bit oh let's look like the
tv
people were like mr harewood i just want
to say thank you so much
my mom had a breakdown my dad had a baby
my uncle this happened to my brother
people were just coming up to me
non-stop
on the street telling me that it
happened to their moms their dads their
brothers their sisters
and it was painful because you know
you'd find yourself on the street
sobbing
complete strangers and what the
documentary did it seemed to give people
license to talk about it
it gave people a language to talk about
it whereas before no one it's
so taboo no one talks about it which i
didn't realize and that's one of the
reasons why i did it is you know people
talk about
anxiety people talk about depression all
the time
nobody talks about psychosis because
it's you lose your mind
okay men and the white coats gonna take
you away how do you know
how do you know you've lost your mind
it's hard but you know it's it's
it's uh when it comes to psychosis it's
normally
it's normally uh preceded by a sort of
mania
like
euphoria you know you see people who've
got you know they're talking like 100
miles an hour
they're really you see people on the
tube and they're covered in colors
bright colors
you know you can see that they're
clearly not quite right
these are people on that they're
starting to just like lose lose their
group with reality
and what can happen is you get these
delusions and you get hallucinations
thought disorders where your thoughts
are jumbled
you know we where you're you're talking
100 miles an hour or you might think you
can control the weather you might think
that you can speak to
aliens from another planet you know
those it's delusions and hallucinations
and
i had them for months and um
you know the reason why a lot of people
don't seek help
is because sometimes it's actually quite
exciting it's like this it's like
dopamine it's like a rush of
adrenaline and dopamine in your mind
you're racing you're
racing and it's hard to it's hard to
to spot your friends might spot it your
friends might say
you know behavior is a bit bizarre today
you know
but you might think i'm [ __ ] great
i'm great
i'm having a great time you know what
i've got this great idea to do so
and you're you know suddenly you're
right in place and i've got one guy who
said to me he wrote the whole play
you know because he just was just
buzzing out of his mind
and it's it's it's it's it's it is
difficult to spot but
you know it's treatment has become
better now and um
if you've got friends or family than
loved ones the earlier they can get you
help the better
the earlier you acknowledge that there's
a problem the better and i
will say this to you that had i had my
breakdown in america
i would be dead i would have been
shocked why is that no
[ __ ] two ways about it i had seven
policemen sitting on me holding me down
in the hospital
to to give me a rapid what they call a
rapid tranquilization
which was to sedate me and uh and
knock me out i was screaming at the top
of my voice
and very distressed and um and i was
very lucky that my friends were
were with me um and was sort of pleading
with everyone around that you know i
just wasn't
a crazy big black man because
the minute you lose it in in out there
on the street particularly in america
if you're going a little bit you could
be homeless or
yes you see it's not it's just it's
what i think they've done really well in
england
what they're starting to do is to
separate
the criminality from the mental health
aspect of it
and and i don't think they do that in
the states if you are
and i think was one guy there a couple
years ago was literally running down the
middle street naked
they put a spit hood on it put a spit
hood on him because we were laughing at
him
and in the end i think he died you know
with by asphyxiating the fixation they
just [ __ ] shot him
so you know i think mental health is a
huge subject in america
black mental health is a huge subject in
america
but i think it's a tricky one to um
broach
uh there's a lot of there's a lot of uh
there's a lot of air around around
mental health around
black mental health you know we're
starting to discuss that in england now
um but but but i you know i'm not sure
it's a conversation that's
what the mental health conversation has
been
really drilled into in the states
inside of you is sponsored by charlie
bear of got
pet products charlie bear is freaking
amazing
my dog blanche has these treats these
charlie bear treats and she goes
freaking bananas
this company also makes hound and gatosk
g-a-t-o-s
and this food as you can see my dog goes
crazy for
and i always say if you're gonna give
yourself a good meal guys these animals
i love animals more than people for the
most part
this is my daughter right this is who i
live with i live alone
i have my dog blanche and i want her to
live long and i want her to eat healthy
and i want her to live
eat good food good healthy treats
and you know what's awesome is my
brother adam adam rosenbaum
works for this company for got prep
products and i love what he does i'm
proud of him
i think this is an amazing company and
uh i'm i'm honored to to be talking
about them
charlie bear let's talk about these
wonderful treats natural dog treats from
our family to your best friend
uh they're made in the usa simple
ingredients
natural ingredients low calorie many
charlie bear
treats only have like three calories
it's amazing pocket friendly
friendly they don't crumble in your
pocket and make a mess don't you hate
that
you're like you know i'll keep a little
treat for the dog in my pocket oh look
at that
i have a handful of crumbs crumbs uh
wallet friendly
high value rewards and most importantly
your dog's gonna love them
your dog's gonna love them charlie bear
look for charlie bear products
at your favorite neighborhood pet stores
and online or visit our website at
www.charliebear.com for more information
and guys that's charlie bear
c-h-a-r-l-e-e-b-e-a-r
charliebear.com www.charliebear.com and
you can also go to www.houndgatos.com
that's hound
and then gatos.com wonderful
amazing food i'm loaded up here and this
is what my
doggy is going to have for the rest of
her existence
charlie bear inside of you is brought to
you by
keeps ryan do you know that two of three
men are gonna experience some form of
hair loss by the time they're 35 years
old and how old are you ryan
i'm 33 years old more than
50 million men in the us suffer from
male pattern baldness
there are only two fda approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
keeps offers both did you hear that two
fda approved medications keeps
offers both they offer a simple
stress-free way to keep your hair
i got a couple friends who are going
bald as well and i'm like
dude it doesn't have to be that
difficult convenient virtual doctor
consultations and medications delivered
straight to your door every three months
you don't have to leave your home
and you know i don't want to leave my
home low cost treatments start at ten
dollars per month
keeps offers generic versions discreet
packaging
and proven results keeps has more five
star reviews
than any of its competitors prevention
is key folks
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so you want to get going
on this
you want to act fast if you are ready to
take action and prevent hair loss go to
k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash inside of you to receive
your first month of treatment
for free that's right for free that's
keeps
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash inside of you
to get your first month free k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash inside of you
so you didn't go in on your own behalf
one of your friends said
it's time like they well how did that
happen a friend of yours
yeah they they uh intervention thing
started to get wind that something
wasn't right and
you know his friends started turning up
at my door and i was like hey great to
see you guys
and you know they'd come in and we'd
speak and i'd crash out for
you know i'd crash out for four hours
and wake up and come back oh you're
still here
you know and they were like [ __ ] me
dave's not something's not right here
so so they it took him a long time to
persuade me to
go to the doctors and then when i
finally went
it didn't go particularly well and um
the doctor was uh just a bit dismissive
really um
and we he gave us a bottle of tablets
and
and um but his dismissive is dismissing
dismissive manner
kind of upset all of us i mean i
remember we all got back to the house
and i looked at the tablets like guys
are we really gonna
what do we think about this and we i
mean all of us sat there and went
i think he was talking bollocks i mean
he threw him in the bin
and uh and and i you know three weeks
later had a massive breakdown
massive psychological breakdown well i
just lost control of it
lost control over the sleeping and i was
very hyper
so so um i'm not but i was lucky that uh
i was lucky that they came back to the
house
and uh found me and decided to try and
drive me to birmingham which was
where my where my mother lived but on
the way
out of london i started passing out
and and uh i think they thought i was
dying
so they drove me to a hospital where i
where i collapsed and was put in a
wheelchair and then left out of his
wheelchair
and ran screaming around the hospital
screaming
i don't remember any of this but i was
and you're not on anything you're not on
anything at this point this is just
the the break yeah and you're screaming
around okay
very very disturbed very
as i say very i have these voices in my
head
i mean it's a whole it's all right we'll
do a whole program
i mean it was extraordinary when you
hear voices in your head
yeah i'm not talking about whispers i'm
talking about full-on
baritone voice echoing around my head
and i'm like wow it's three o'clock in
the morning
and it's martin luther king david i'm
here to tell you
the next stage um i'm [ __ ] hearing
his voice in my head
and i'm like he's telling me this whole
[ __ ] thing about
his galactic his [ __ ]
extraterrestrial looking
he was telling me that the minute he was
such a crazy idea but
the minute he was shot he said the
minute he died
reality became he said i remember i did
that speech i have a dream i said yes
he says well i'm speaking to you now
reality is my dream and you are living
in my dream
and uh i have to i'm i'm
i'm i'm contacting various various
people around the world
who tonight are going to sacrifice
themselves and
close the gap between good and evil and
rig the world of
poverty and illness and badness it was
huge
wow [ __ ] cute and i'm sobbing in my
bedroom thinking this is extraordinary
it can't be really said yes it's all
real you have to get up you have to walk
to this place
walk to camden which was about an hour
walk from where i lived
and i walked all the way to this place
that he told me to walk to
and obviously it was [ __ ] close it's
three o'clock in the morning and then i
and and i i was like this is this isn't
this isn't this isn't right
something's wrong and then he gets in my
ear and he goes baby you've got to be
very careful things are really going
wrong and
it was extraordinary and uh that was the
night it all went
horribly wrong and the following day i
was section
and spent five days on a mental ward
um uh being being given
three times the legal dose of tranquil
life of of sedatives now this is the
other thing
you know you've got a big black man on
your
psych ward you're terrified of him what
do you do
you knock him the [ __ ] out so i was
given
and this is i've only found this 30
years later
and and and you know having given it to
a
psychotherapist to to to cast their eye
over
she said well the first thing i'm going
to say is you were given three times the
legal doses of
tranquilizers and i have no idea why
and i said well they were trying to
knock you out she said they were just
literally trying to get put you out
but you can imagine that look at the
killings and that happened
yeah and people die
the reason why and it's all in the
documentary but the reason why
the the loads of people were
dying whilst being restrained by the
police
and lots of people do die um
being restrained while they're being
medicated
uh and being restrained while they're
being arrested
so they're trying to take the
criminality out of
your mental health experience so this
this there's
a whole section in the documentary where
i speak to
this new a new a new uh
it's a new way of working in in
birmingham where i'm from
which is where rather than sending the
police on mental health
if there's a mental health aspect if
someone's running down the street naked
the guy is obviously
clearly not well so rather than calling
the police
you will call a special unit
which is made up of a mental health
nurse
a social worker a pediatrician
um uh a policeman
and uh so it's a it's more holistic
right so rather than the copper jumping
out and bashing over the head it might
be the mental health nurse that gets out
and tries to talk to you
assess the situation get you one and
then they start working out
what how what's the best way to treat
this person
rather than putting him in [ __ ]
handcuffs throwing him in the back of
the police van
and locking him in the police cell four
hours which is what happened to me wow
what was it that sort of saved you in a
way sort of
obviously they had to get you on a
certain medication probably an
antipsychotic or something or they
what was it that just it was just a
between therapy and getting you in the
right
meds and getting your head straight i
mean how did that how did that all work
no idea you know i i um
um you know i mean i i
was basically given a bottle of tablets
and you know the old gag keep taking the
tablets you know
i was released from my five days of of
of institutionalized sort of medication
and just given a bottle of tablets and
um
you know very very quickly slightly
spinning out of control again
uh soon after that uh but my mother was
great my mother basically just
took me back to her place i went left
london went back to
my mom's place and she uh
she uh observed me like a hawk for about
a month
giving me half a tablet and giving me a
quarter of a tablet and giving me
you know little bites of a tablet right
slowly weaning me off this
medication and i'm lucky that that you
know i'm
i think there's 15 percent of people in
on
15 of psychotic patients who never need
further medication uh or or never have
never had further issues and i guess i
fall into that
category because i've never really
needed anything since since
that last quarter a tablet wow
talk about intense and by the way the
documentary again is my psychosis in me
on the bbc
correct psychosis psychosis in me
i mean you know
did you for a while think that i why did
i why was i so open about this this is
going to ruin my
career did you have those thoughts in
the beginning and then
obviously it hasn't got scared the night
it went out i mean i
i you know i watched it for a year
because we shot it and then the bbc
didn't want to didn't want to put it out
until
the following year because they wanted
to put it out in the whole season
on mental health films and when i first
saw the trailer
i was [ __ ] terrified i suddenly
panicked and i thought
why didn't
i didn't watch it i was really scared
and the minute it finished i went to bed
i went to bed early
and the minute it finished just every
device
every device in the house was pinging
ringing buzzing bleeping
and it was just emails and texts from
people who saw it who had seen it
just like just blown away by it and
um blown away by what it what it was
what it was revealing because i meet
other people who are suffering from
psychosis
you know i think we did more in an hour
to reduce the stigma of psychosis
than it has been in like 20 years yeah
because some people were talking about
it
and calls about psychosis to them to the
mental health charity mind
in england rose by 107
the next day so people were suddenly
going you know what i think i've got a
problem well you know what i think my
son's having a problem
do you know what i think now i know what
it is now now i know
you know i need to speak something about
it and now all the health officials in
england are going that [ __ ] david
harewood we're overwhelmed now
what the [ __ ] did he do don't show the
documentary again
my god so look um supergirl
bad transition however it's a transition
did you know anything about did you know
anything about jon jones martian
manhunter
uh at all when you first got this
because i don't even know anything
really about him anyway i mean
what did you do to prepare they said you
have an audition for this or did you
just get an offer for it or
no i got it i got an offer to play uh i
was originally just playing hank henshaw
the guy who runs the deo right um
i think jeff jones and andrew kreitzberg
were
watching the pilot being
shot one day and i i think
jeff john said [ __ ] guy's great you
know he'd make a great martial manhattan
and they looked at each other and then
[ __ ] do it so
they just sort of they didn't tell me
about it they only told me after the
pilot finished
so once i was in england and shooting a
job in morocco called the night manager
and they my man my agent called me and
said
yeah they want to make you an offer on
that supergirl but they want to change
your character i was like what
i said yeah they want to make you
somebody else and i was like well who's
that
and i emailed the bosses and they were
saying well it's very exciting but we're
not going to tell you
until it's all you know all the you know
crosses of datsun's eye you know all you
know everything's signed up
and i i flew to la to shoot the pilot
and i think i got there two weeks early
or something and i phoned up and i said
guys you know
i need to know who the [ __ ] i'm playing
you know i thought can i come and meet
someone
when i come and come in and meet you
guys so i went in to meet andrew
and he just gave me this pile of comics
and said
you're going to be the martial manhunter
and um
you said who i never know
[Laughter]
the hulk fantastic four i didn't read dc
i wasn't a dc i never read anything i
think i was lex luthor i never read one
comic book i didn't know i just said
[ __ ] it
i'm gonna i get it i know all over all
over comics
so so i so but i didn't know the story
so
i went home and read the martial and
hunter [ __ ] loved it
loved it i just thought he was great
great character so um
yeah it's been it's been fun it's been
slightly you know
you know they they can't quite afford
you know
he's one of the strongest most capable
characters in the dc camera but they
just can't afford to do his powers
so like you know it's like i'm i'm
playing him on a budget it's
so i i i'm like
so it's been it's been really it's been
like sometimes i get my butt kicks i'm
like
how the [ __ ] is this guy beating me up
you know you know so
[Music]
often times oftentimes i've had to sort
of
you know just create create create a
kind of whole new iteration of the
character because
um it doesn't quite match
you know with this sort of all-powerful
fantastically capable character that's
in in the comic books
you know um it's like it's not my show i
can't save the day
right so if people go she has to save
the day
so so um so a lot of the times i have to
sort of
i i suspect i suspect in the very first
season
just before the finale i'll get taken
out you know i'll get taken out by some
radiation [ __ ] beam from space that
knocks me out that i can't
save the day you know you know and it
happens
every it happened in everything
before the finale i'd get some sort of
some [ __ ] alien stone
placed around my neck which disabled me
for
me what have you what have you not done
as a as that character
that fans are like well he could do this
why isn't he doing that
we can read minds he can um uh
uh he can uh teleport
i mean there's a whole list of them out
there on on on
on online right right he's
he's an extremely capable character but
unfortunately
we just can't afford it so so it's it's
been like
it's been like playing them on a bit of
a budget is it weird being in the final
season of a show that
when someone i don't know if anybody's
ever said this is your final season no
one's ever told me that
so you never know but as an actor is it
harder to go in there and
have something to really you know want
to would you just suck it up and
how does that work i was quite i'm i'm
quite
i'm ready i'm ready i'm ready to check
out i've got to be honest i'm ready to
i'm ready to move on so it was quite it
was quite a relief
when they said it's the final season i
was i was okay with that
okay i'm kind of i'm okay with going
home
i'm okay with being around my family um
i took the job for a specific reason and
those reasons have been that box has
been ticked
um you know it's it's got some some some
money in the bank which has been great
cemented my you know
my sort of uh uh
position as you know as a as an actor in
the america in the american sort of
a world and you got more fans it's got a
shitload of fans now you got a shitload
of fans that love marsha manhunter fans
um it's been great so you know so but
i'm i'm ready to ch i'm ready to move on
it's it's it's like it's like doing
panto for like 17 years
you know at some point you want to move
on yeah and and
do another genre yeah all right this is
called [ __ ] talking with david harewood
this is
rapid fire these are from fans on my
patreon lovely patreon go to patreon.com
inside inside mary b if there were
really extraterrestrials do you think
they would be friendly or hostile
uh on supergirl you have a mix of both
on supergirl
i think that'd be a mix of both mikey
how was it to play matt
martian manhunter opposite two justice
league uh voice veterans and one who
voiced martian manhunter in the animated
series
awesome columbia i worked absolutely
brilliant and i i love the bearing
uh it was a real pleasure being on set
taylor k
david is there anything in your career
that a producer director wanted you to
do that you weren't comfortable with
uh not really no i'm trying to i
don't try to throw myself in sophie m do
you have a favorite guest star who has
appeared on supergirl
columbia wasn't he the best i worked
with him on uh justice league and we
i love him i just had him on the podcast
amazing he's a lovely man a genuinely
lovely man i miss him i agree
connor w i have a lot of respect for
your charity work including soccer aide
my question is what was the episode in
supergirl that made you most nervous
going in i am the most nervous
um did you have to get naked or
something i've never been naked because
there's no new seeds
um i would say i would say
just for some of the emotional stuff
some of the emotions that he talks about
his family that's something that you
know because
that takes you to a dark place it always
takes you to you know you have to
you have to always have to pull on pull
on some some pretty
emotional strings when you start talking
about the uh
you know the loss of his family and
sometimes they were
you know they were they were tough to do
august c what character did you view
totally different as a child versus as
an
adult hulk
uh you know you know for me it was
always that the hulk was always smash
smash hulk and and uh you know
i i i loved it i i it's a big green man
i loved it but i guess as
i've grown older you know and i love how
marvel have you know
made him made him more of a thinking
thinking
beast as it were uh i i i like that
that's mine
that's a good change well look i i
really love how open you are it's
certainly
gonna touch a lot of people and you've
already touched a lot of people with um
your mental health
ambassadorship i'm gonna make that word
up you like that ambassadorship
i don't think it's a word but you were
you're awesome on homeland and you
worked with my friend marina backron
did you have scenes with her ever yes i
did yes lots of scenes she's great she's
[ __ ] awesome
yeah i mean i wish i had more to do with
her but but yeah she's she's
she's a great girl well uh what's your
handles so people could follow you
just add david all there all one word my
name david
d-a-v-i-d h-a-r-e-w double
o d well this has been a real treat i
really appreciate you being on here i
hope you had fun it wasn't bad right oh
yeah it's great i mean i loved you i i
love your style
uh it's been fun it has been fun i hope
you come back and good luck continue
success with everything
get your covet test all my health and
happiness to you buddy
that was powerful yeah i mean
you know you try not to poke or try to
but i always want to go deeper like well
but why is that well what did you
you know i'm always trying to figure out
like how it happens and
he painted the picture pretty pretty
good pretty
pretty well yeah he's really been
through it he's been through it and i
think
i think when you're through and you can
address that you've been through it i
think it just makes you stronger it
really does they always say what doesn't
kill you makes you stronger and yeah
i mean to be so honest too
i i know a lot of people if they had any
kind of break
first of all would never go get checked
in would never agree to anything or if
they did they would not let anyone ever
know they didn't feel shame
and i don't know how many times i've
told you guys that um
the only way i mean we're gonna ever
really
love ourselves and love others at least
for me is if you start to acknowledge
who you really are
and be honest to yourself and take care
of yourself
so um anyway yeah that
that hit me that hit me pretty strong uh
remembering the concert
it is our concert is this saturday may
29th it's online you can watch it please
watch it if you haven't listen
watched us sun spin two shows 2 p.m 6
p.m pacific standard time
there's prizes there's zooms there's uh
you know it's gonna be a lot of fun in
fact the top bidder
gets a uh uh an encore
we zoom them with an encore if they want
with a couple songs oh nice
so it'll be nice and you can go to
sunspin.com for all the information book
the band
book a zoom with us anything you want
we'll have fun we always have fun
and if you want any inside of you merch
go to the inside of you online store
there's tons of great stuff let's give a
discount code for today
how about ryan's vaxxed
15. how many x's ryan's vax no
apostrophe 1x
ryan's vaxxed 15
for 15 off the inside you online store
likes luther pictures in smallville and
inside of you mugs and shirts and
a bunch of great stuff i have some fanny
packs left i think i only have like
three
two maybe one or two fanny packs oh so
get them while they last
autographed tumblers autographed hats
whatever you want it's all there
the inside of you online store and ryan
again if they want to subscribe to the
show
uh go to apple podcast spotify or you go
to youtube.com
inside of you with michael rosenbaum you
can go to
twitter inside of you pod instagram
inside of your podcast and
facebook also at inside of you podcast
that's correct
that is correct uh my lovely patrons my
lovely page i was
reading a lot of great funny comments
people always have
their opinions and i like their opinions
and they have like ideas
and sometimes their ideas are really
good for guests i actually have gotten
quite a few guests based on
people's opinions or suggestions
isn't that something that's helpful yeah
if you're a patron i listen to you
i don't always listen to you it's
impossible to listen to all of you
there's a lot of you there's a lot of
you and i love you all in fact we're
gonna name you all right now
and then we're gonna give it up for the
big surprise
so here it is uh these are the uh all
the patrons bear with me it's only a few
minutes but i love them all and they
contribute to the show
if you want to join patreon patreon.com
inside of you nancy d
mary b leah f tricia f cerave little
lisa yukiko jill e bryan h
lauren g nico p robin s jerry w robert b
jason w apothea and kristen k amelia oh
allison l lucas m raj
see joshua d emily s cjp samantha m
jennifer and jackie p stacy l carly h
carly s
jen s jamal f janelle b kerry b
tab of the 272 not to be confused with
tabitha 273
ashley ryan kimberly mike e marissa and
eldon sopremo 99 mor ramirez santiago m
sarah half chad w leanne p ray a
maya p maddie s kendrick f ashley f
shannon and d
matt w they're all right here they're
right right here on the screen you can
see them and you hear them
ashley e shannon d matt w belinda n
kevin
v james r chris h dave h samantha s
spider-man chase sheila g ray h
tabitha t tom and suzanne
b katie f how are you doing this
i'm remembering liliana as
s a a michelle k marcus w
hannah b michael s talia m luke h
andrew c t t betsy
frost d not betsy ross okay claire
m she didn't do the flag liz j laura
l we're almost done here chad l rochelle
eid nathan e brandel d
taylor k neil a marion meg k janel p
trav l dan ann jennifer j
wayne m diana ogetta lorraine g olga c
corey m carey h veronica k big stevie w
kendall t lindsay m carroll d kdg
sandy b angel m eric c rhiannon c
stephen m cory k super sam emily c
sherry s coleman g michelle a riley j
liz l and jeremy c those are the patrons
the wonderful patrons
and now for the surprise you've all been
waiting for this entire time ryan is vac
we've been dying to do this
it's been a year i'm vaxxed and we're
gonna hug it out
[Music]
[Applause]
feels good that felt good
that don't feel good i smell good thanks
man it's uh burberry britt i wear
oh yeah that felt good my old friend
ryan i got to hug him oh thank god he
waited over a year for that
that's your surprise you're like that's
the surprise come here blanche
say hello to everybody come here oh my
god come here come here no
no get over here come here come here
right here yes you're a little good
girl a little good girl right there
people don't want to hear this
uh i love you guys thank you so much for
all the uh
support and love and dedication to the
show
spread the word i know you do i see your
tweets i see your
messages you're so damn awesome so thank
you
thank you and thank you listeners if
you're here for david harewood and
uh hopefully you'll stick around for the
next one from
myself michael rosenbaum and uh myself
ryan tears
here in the hollywood hills hollywood
hills california uh
let's take a look up at the camera give
a wave of the camera up there hey guys
we love you thank you for allowing to be
ian let me thank you for allowing me to
be inside of each
and every one of you till next time
promise me you'll be good to yourself
be grateful um life's good man we're
here let's try to make the most of it
that's my dog you agree blanche she
agrees
all right blanche now beat it all right
love you guys
[Music]
thanks